um it's crazy too because like what I
appreciated about you is like you really
love to play in the game and when I look
at like your career obviously you had a
very successful NBA career but at a
certain point in time you even like went
and played in China right right so that
was at the end so yeah so but I'm saying
like you don't go and play in China at
the end unless you just love to hoop
yeah I love the game that's like to your
point like
as I was coming up that's all I could
think about was basketball right you
know what I'm saying like if somebody
told me to shut up and jump I might have
listened at that point you understand
what I'm saying like I mean that's how
much I love the game everything that I
did was around trying to get better
trying to feel better so that's why I
like you know a lot of my teammates and
a lot of my older friends like any time
there's like any type of new technology
of a surgery or a diet they always hit
me up because they know I've tried like
everything yeah just to get another year
I've always I just wanted to play better
I just wanted to be better I want to
feel better I want to you know I just
want to be the best that I could be at
all times and you know when I got
towards the end you know I had a botched
knee surgery and I had got a staph
infection from the surgery didn't know I
had it ended up getting my bloodstream
you know could have died from it you
know I had to stay in the hospital pick
line the whole [__] and you know anyway
all the articulating cartilage in my
needs so what that is is pretty much
like what it protects the bone and you
know I'm bone on bone so I actually need
a knee replacement
um I've been able to avoid a knee
replacement because of cannabis
so you know I've been able to have an
unbelievable quality of life retired but
when the China opportunity came it was
because of Stephan Marbury who was who
was like a god there yeah people don't
understand like a lot of people by the
way go watch this documentary I bought
it Stefan Mulberry is one of my favorite
NBA players ever when I was a kid
when the sun's traded for him I was very
excited
um but yeah in China he was I think they
have a statue he got a statue of him in
Beijing of all places yeah you know what
I'm saying and you know he called me and
he was like are you done and I was like
no I'm not done man I'm waiting on a
couple teams you know Houston maybe you
know James Harden was trying to get me
to Houston and different things like but
he had Mike danfone as his coach so that
wasn't going to happen but uh so shots
fired for sure but uh he um he called me
and he was like yo I got a couple teams
over here you know what I'm saying so he
gave me a list of teams and I was asking
what is it he was like the one I picked
was fujin the fujin uh sturgeons and uh
the reason why I went there was because
of the weather and it was close to Hong
Kong so he was just like whatever you
get a day off you just fly to Hong Kong
and eat regular food and then come back
type thing and uh I ended up being at 56
days bro I couldn't make it shout out to
Future great mix 56 nights literally 56
days bro 56 days it was the day when I
was flying in I knew I wasn't gonna make
it I'll just look or you could just tell
yeah I'm sure you're like this ain't I
can't do this it's just like at the you
know at the end of the day like I say
all money ain't good money listen early
in my radio career my first full-time
job I did afternoons at a station in
Boise Idaho oh [__] and as soon as I got
there I said well I'm not gonna be here
longer than a year so this [__] is cool
but I think for me you know what I'm
saying yeah I told the general manager
which was this lady named Ricky who knew
nothing about basketball so I was like
we're not going to win no game because
the other thing about China which is
cool so you know I had like a three
million dollar contract was only for
three and a half months right so it's
really no time but you also you get paid
a bonus every time you win and like my
bonus was five thousand dollars cash
every win that Ricky literally comes
after the game and gives me cash and
after like the first couple preseason
games I was like bro I'm not gonna make
any extra money we suck who are these
guys on this team like how did you put
this team together you know what I'm
saying so I went to her like maybe after
the third game of the season and I was
like I'm gonna give you till
Thanksgiving you got to find my
replacement you know what I'm saying so
I got a body I laid it home on
Thanksgiving Day I kissed the ground
when I got home no [__] and uh you
know that was my China experience shout
out to Dwight man Dwight's out there
shooting threes I got some other [__]
going on I saw it up today he got I mean
listen man allegedly because all right
I'm like you never know with the
internet what's doctored and right you
know so I I don't want to put that on
them like why are they doing that to my
man yeah I don't want to put that on
Dwight because I don't know if that's a
thing because again it's the internet I
saw the screenshots
crazy it does look really crazy and also
if that's what he's into whatever right
God bless you shout out to Dwight